la pulvérisation démocratique où les
clivages façon puzzle d'héritière et
c'est parti pour la lecture de cet
article de 2021 parue dans la revue
pouvoirs comme à chaque fois je surligne
ce qui me semble intéressant et je le
lis avec vous ce qui n'est pas sûr ligne
et c'est pas que c'est pas intéressant
c'est que bon voilà c'est un membre je
ne peux pas tout lire sinon ça
deviendrait vraiment rébarbatif mais je
vous conseille d'acquérir l'article et
de le lire tranquillement au complet
chez vous si l'objet vous intéresse
alors on va parler le thème l'objet
vraiment de l'article c'est l'équivalent
je vous en ai parlé on définira plus
tard ce que c est en fait il ya deux
grands auteurs qui ont travaillé sur
cette question des cuvelages dès que
vous ouvrez un bouquin de sciences
politiques et que vous cherchez le mot
clivage vous retrouver l'ip sète hérault
kahn qui en 1967 travail profondément
sur ce concept de clivage les
contributions qui précède rappelle
comment cette matrice intellectuelle a
participé puissamment à la compréhension
de l'organisation de nos systèmes
partisans moi j'ai fait mes études dans
les années 2000 et en effet cette
question des clivages était vraiment
centrale dès qu'on faisait de l'analyse
de partis politiques et de politique au
sens
premier du terme j'en veux dire elle a
pu aussi avoir un effet performatif
alors un effet performatif c'est de
créer quelque chose finalement ce n'est
pas seulement de rester une élucubration
intellectuel mais c'est aussi d'avoir un
effet sur le réel
elle a installé l'idée que ces
formations étaient solidement établie
dans le système politique
donc les parties on parle des partis
politiques ici
à partir de là sans doute n'at-on pas
été assez attentif aux dérèglements
profond qui ont affecté nos démocraties
et on comprend directement ici la
problématique qui va se mettre en place
c'est qu'on a une théorie qui est
hégémonique dans la science politique et
dans la compréhension des partis
politiques et que finalement on ne se
rend pas compte que peut-être que cette
théorie était situé historiquement et
que les évolutions postérieures ont
rendu certains aspects de cette théorie
obsolète je pense qu'en disant cela je
ne déforme pas
le travail d'éric tiers je pense que
c'est dans ce sens là qui voulait qu'il
voulait aller il est un moyen permettant
de se distinguer de l'adversaire et
d'organiser symboliquement la
compétition démocratique pour accéder au
pouvoir on parle bien sûr du clivage
est
souvent quand on aborde en premier la
politique moi je le fais régulièrement
avec des élèves de secondaire est bien
la première question qui jaillissent et
mais la gauche et la droite c'est quoi
exactement est tout de suite dans la
foulée il ya un mini-débat qui se fait
ou un petit tumulte comme ça qui se fait
dans la classe et chacun se positionne
directement par rapport à ce qu'il va
joue si en classe je balance le nom d'un
dirigeant politique ou d'un parti ils
vont directement se positionner pour ou
contre ce personnage ce parti et donc on
voit que même en n'ayant pas une
connaissance approfondie puisqu'on ne
sait parfois même pas
définir soi même
le clivage de joie ton va faire
référence à ce clivage est à d'autres
clivages pour se situer politiquement
donc c'est tout à fait intéressant parce
que le clivage gauche droite évidemment
c'est quelque chose qui en sciences
politiques est fortement débattue il
certainement qu'il n'y a pas d'unanimité
sur la définition de ce clivage gauche
droite mais tout le monde en parle et on
je retrouve bien ici voilà il est un
moyen permettant de se distinguer de
l'adversaire est organisée
symboliquement la compétition
démocratique pour accéder au pouvoir
c'est à cet après midi pour préparer les
différentes émissions politiques qu'on
est ensemble j'ai regardé en vitesse
quelques minutes du meeting de eric
zemmour et il a vraiment clivé
énormément droite contre gauche en
essayant de rassembler la droite et on
voit que son but ici est d'essayer de
cliver
et donc ce concept indépendamment de ce
qu'ont à 10 précédemment ce concept
reste tout à fait pertinent à certains
égards parce qu'en tout cas il est
utilisé par les politiques est ici dans
l'article on nous parle de nicolas
sarkozy ou de eric worth 1 qui
maintenant est passé chez mâcon mais qui
était un ministre de sarko
et il nous donne un exemple que voilà
ils ont sévèrement clivé justement pour
des fins électorales quoi
et c'est vrai que si vous ne privez pas
on a l'impression que politiquement ça
ne marche pas forcément
en satisfaisant sa base électorale et en
radicalisant parfois son discours le
président parallèlement pour objectif de
cliver d'affirmer des différences
politiques irréductibles afin de mettre
mal à l'aise l'opposition et de toucher
les franges populaires ou insécure de
l'électorat au risque d'ailleurs de se
priver de l'électorat modéré c'est
évidemment un jeu dangereux parfois de
cliver parce que si tu clip de trop si
tu vas trop dans la caricature bien
l'électorat modéré comme les dc il va
échapper c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé avec la campagne de valérie
pécresse qui a fait une campagne très à
droite et qui finalement s'est coupé de
son électorat centriste qui a été dans
les bras de macron sur la base de cet
exemple on constate ainsi que l'on
observe également
que l'observé galement de maillard est
sûre elle que le clivage comme
instrument de mobilisation politique
n'interdit pas de rechercher
parallèlement ce que l'on a pu appeler
l'ouverture et qui se manifestent
d'ordinaire par la fraction à soi de
quelques personnalités d'opposition
c'est ce que sarkozy avait fait en
essayant d'aller chercher des
des ministres ou des soutiens à gauche
on peut aussi penser évidemment à mâcon
qui va chercher à gauche et à droite des
hommes politiques ou des femmes
politiques
d'ailleurs parlons-en des manuels macron
et l'auteur nous en parle l'élection d'
emmanuel macron et la mise en avant du
fameux en même temps à vous savez qu
emmanuel macron c'est en même temps de
gauche et en même temps de droite ont
suscité toute une littérature et un
débat sur la disparition du clivage
gauche-droite au doigt de gauche est ce
que finalement une ce clivage qui est le
méga clivages on pourrait dire mes gars
n'est pas le mot c'est le méta clivages
je dirais que le clivage gauche droite
est le méta clivages politiques qui
vient recouvrir l'ensemble des autres
clivages encore une fois si ce que je
vous dis ici vous semble obscur
retourner sur cette vidéo
politique gauche droite à comprendre ce
que veut dire droite et gauche en
politique et vous aurez vraiment les
réponses à vos questions alors j'ai été
inondé de certains commentaires je
trouve un peu
hein pas de mauvaise foi mais plein d'
incompréhension par rapport à mon
travail je me suis vraiment basé sur des
travaux politique pour essayer de de
synthétiser ce clivage gauche droite à
partir de différents clivages parce que
ceux qui vous disent que la gauche et la
droite
il y à une naissance derrière qui
essentialiste finalement cette gauche et
cette droite eh bien ils se mettent le
doigt dans l'oeil est il seul enfonce
jusqu'au coude parce que le clivage
gauche droite il est très comment dire
relatif il est trés situer dans l'espace
et dans le temps vous ne serez pas à
droite de la même façon si vous êtes aux
états unis que vous êtes si vous êtes en
france ou en belgique et donc
la gauche à droite finalement pour moi
c'est vraiment ce méta clivage qui vient
recouvrir d'autres clivages que vous
irez voir la vidéo si ça vous intéresse
alors je rappelle que aujourd'hui on
résume un article de science sociale
plutôt de sciences politiques et
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse au clivage
est ce que les clivages sont encore
d'actualité notamment ce clivage gauche
droite haut droite gauche
cette fracture unis car elle est un
facteur d'intégration politique des
citoyens qui se retrouvent dans ce
clivage et c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure même si on dénonce le clivage
droite gauche et les autres clivages ça
peut être des guides et des clivages
éthique des clivages socio économiques
des clivages centre périphérie des
clivages linguistiques eh bien on va
quand même utilisé ces clivages parce
que en fait ça nous permet vraiment de
construire notre identité politique et
voyez cette intégration politique des
citoyens est vraiment quelque chose
d'essentiel dans ce concept des clivages
il est autant un élément structurant
cannes éléments
structure et j'ai envie de dire mais là
je fais un peu trop mou bourdieu à deux
balles l'émergence des forces
écologistes et le retour de l'extrême
droite modifiant le paysage partisan
dont la plupart des démocraties à
compter des années 1970 ont conduit à se
demander comment réinterpréter le modèle
de lipsett héros can oui parce que le
clivage précédent on avait des partis de
gauche les partis de droite 1
le rpr à l'époque qui est opposé au ps
en france où le prl en belgique qui est
aussi opposé au ps là on avait un
clivage socio économique très très clair
et puis on avait parfois certains partis
de la démocratie chrétienne l'udf ou à
l'époque le psc qui est devenu le cdh
maintenant les engagés en belgique et
donc on avait un modèle qui était
relativement clair mais sur sa vient se
greffer la question des partis
écologistes et des partis d'extrême
droite et j'ai envie de dire encore plus
en belgique avec les partis
nationalistes
commentait ce que ça vient jouer est ce
que cette théorie de lipsett et rock'n
est dépassé à partir de ces années 70 où
ces nouveaux partis émergent finalement
et on nous rappelle que le modèle de
lipsett et rock'n il est basé sur
une approche très historiciste très
historique de la construction des
clivages on nous dit qu'il ya eu
différentes révolutions d'abord une
révolution nationale une révolution
industrielle
qui ont construit cette différentes les
clivages traditionnels mais
qu'aujourd'hui l'auteur nous propose
qu'il y a une révolution anthropologique
qui vient explosé véritablement
désintégrer ces clivages et atomisé les
identités politiques voilà ça c'est
vraiment l'hypothèse de cet article
qu'il nous présente ici assez rapidement
j'espère que j'ai bien fait comprendre
l'articulation qu'il y avait avec la
théorie de lipsett et rock'n
alors en réalité nous assistons nous
prenons dit héritière à une
pulvérisation démocratique donc il faut
bien comprendre la pulvérisation c'est
vraiment l'explosion mais on vraiment de
très fines particules
cette notion que nous souhaiterions
distinguer des fragmentations et si je
comprends bien son arrêt de l'article
la fragmentation c'est vraiment d'avoir
des gros morceaux tandis que la
pulvérisation c'est à dire qu'il vous
reste quasi plus rien quoi c'est de la
matière mais vraiment décomposé en très
fines partie
si communément évoqué renvoi deux
réalités 1 la réduction en poudre de la
société avec une atomisation des acteurs
autour de l'idée que nous avions
développée naguère l'émergence de lego
démocrate
donc on est sur un phénomène politique
ou c'est de plus en plus difficile de
réfléchir en termes collectif et chacun
va réussir va réagir ou va se comporter
à titre individuel alors qu'avant on
avait des des conscience de classe
qui permettait finalement la
constitution de gros blocs sur base des
clivages qui traversait la société
alors irrite hier sous nos yeux si il ya
la projection en fines particules des
idées dans ce qui ne constitue plus un
débat structuré démocratique mais une
suite ininterrompue de clash de punch
line et autres tweets sans cohérence ni
possibilité de les organiser pour
composer les éléments d'une délibération
collective et jeux directement mettre un
parent peut enfin lancer un pavé dans la
mare ici
2 1 j'apprécie énormément le le côté
très littéraire où le choix des mots
très imagé les métaphores qui sont
utilisés par héritière mais
est ce que est ce que ici on est
vraiment sur quelque chose qui ressemble
à de l'action sociale parce que moi ce
qui me semble manquer
dans l'exercice qui est fait ici c'est
un travail empirique vous allez me dire
oui mais plus tard il va vérifier cette
hypothèse par rapport à des données
tirées du réel eh bien pas du tout et je
me demande dans quelle mesure alors
peut-être qu'il ya des travaux connexes
mais comme il n'ya pas non plus de
bibliographie à la fin c'est assez
compliqué alors voyez on est déjà face à
certains
éléments qui résiste quand même à notre
à notre jugement
ben on sait pas dire finalement si s'il
ne transmet pas ici des représentations
personnel j'ai envie de dire
voilà parce que sk l'époque est-ce qu'en
1981 est ce que la politique était autre
chose qu une suite ininterrompue de
clash le punch line et autres tweets
sans cohérence évidemment il n'ya pas
les tweets sans cohérence mais quand on
voit les petites phrases qui sont donnés
lors des débats voilà cdd question qu'on
peut se poser quoi moi j'ai vraiment eu
un jeu pas dire un malaise je parais
jusque là mais voilà je n'ai pas été
convaincu par parce qu'au t2 de
l'article mais attention je n'ai pas dit
que l'article était et est inintéressant
à mon sens ce qui est très intéressant
dans l'article c'est la problématique
qu'il pose
est ce que les clivages sont toujours
actuelles en fait c'est cette question
là qui est intéressante à mon avis à
traiter et à quelques éléments communs
on va voir ça
alors il y aussi la violence qui est la
forme que prend souvent ces
pulvérisations démocratique on peut
faire aussi référence à ce qu'a dit
zemmour ou ce que la foule dans le
meeting de zemmour d'aujourd'hui à
scander macron est un assassin ou
quelque chose comme ça donc évidemment
il ya beaucoup de violence dans la
politique
et la destruction qui est sa conséquence
d'extraction des conditions du débat des
organisations censé animer la vie
politique et peut-être la possibilité de
vivre ensemble moi je trouve que
l'auteur va très loin kloter embrasse de
nombreuses idées des idées très
générales qui me semble difficilement
vérifiables et personnellement voilà moi
je mets laser sur cet article
partout ça parce qu'après voilà vous
verrez que c'est pas forcément étayée
sur des données empiriques sur cette
base nous imitons nous émettons
l'hypothèse que la pulvérisation
démocratique peut conduire à l'inanité
de la notion même de clivages et cette
hypothèse me semble un falsifiable dans
le sens où elle utilise un peu elle peut
conduire ça pourrait oui mais ça
pourrait pas alors que normalement une
hypothèse doit être falsifiable ça veut
dire qu'elle peut être réfutée
tandis qu'ici sa formulation même nous
empêche de la réfuter parce que c'est
peut conduire ou pas et voyez ses sept
petits ce petit mot qui va faire que on
peut se demander si si on peut apporter
une réponse totalement négative à 7
cette hypothèse a une réputation à cette
hypothèse autrement dit elle rendrait
obsolète tout projet de structuration de
la vie politique sur le faux rebond sur
le fondement des distinctions collectif
est donc ici revient sur la théorie de
lipsett héros kahn qui je vous le disais
se basait en fait sur des révolutions
qui ont elles mêmes instauré différents
clivages il ya la révolution nationale
la révolution industrielle donc la
révolution nationale sur les guerres de
religion avec la réforme la contre
réforme au 16e 17e siècle d'où weissach
montre l'affirmation de la nation avec
en ouverture la révolution de 1989 mais
789 pardon et toutes les révolutions
européennes qui ont pu suivre évidemment
et la révolution industrielle au 19e
siècle avec la révolution russe de 1917
qui ont chacune cristallisé deux types
de conflits l'intégrité rial culturel et
l'autre fonctionnel alors on va
expliquer ce que c'est tout d'abord la
révolution nationale a conduit à
l'émergence d'un clivage territoriale
culturelle fondée sur l'opposition entre
le centre et la périphérie autrement dit
les villes et les campagnes pour le dire
simplement
et un clivage fonctionnel reposant sur
l'opposition entre laïcs et cléricale la
révolution contre l'industriel a eu
quant à elle pour conséquence la
construction d'un clivage territoriale
culturel entre les intérêts à gré et
ceux de la classe montante des
entrepreneurs industriels donc
agriculture contre industrie et d'un
clivage fonctionnelle entre les
possédants et ceux qui ne le sont pas
dans les pays démocratiques
les parties se sont ainsi formées aux
coûts des 19e et 20e siècles selon ces
clivages en regroupant des citoyens qui
fort d'une identité sociale affirmée se
retrouvait dans cette formation qui
donnait une traduction politique à leurs
revendications et à leur vision du monde
et on voit ici qu'en fait le clivage est
à
2-2 échelle à une échelle sociale ou
sociétale où on va avoir des oppositions
entre différentes catégories de
population mais ce clivage social est
recouvert par un clivage politique qui
va venir structuré et donner une
visibilité politique et permettre une
lutte pour le pouvoir
par ces différentes répartition et donc
ces paraphes ces différents clivages
pardon
mais au fond qu'est ce qu'un qui va chez
lipp sète hérault kahn n'en donne pas de
définition précise et il nous laisse un
petit peu le bec dans l'eau résulte de
l'opposition durable d'intérêts entre
deux segments de la population voilà ce
que serait le clivage ou de manière plus
développés qu'il est une division
profonde sur un enjeu majeur fondé sur
un sentiment de déséquilibre ou de
domination qui conduit des groupes et
ensuite des partis à s'organiser pour
réduire ce déséquilibre ce qui engendre
des tensions persistantes avec la partie
de la société qui se voit ainsi contesté
en fait en belgique par exemple on a
trois grandes divas gea le clivage
flamand ou wallon le clivage
linguistique et active âge religion
laïque qu'on a vu ici plus haut et puis
il ya le clivage socio-économique un
possédant contre travailleurs
tout simplement quoi
alors aujourd'hui les clivages qu'on
pourrait retrouver c'est le grand
clivage dont on parle c'est les élites
contre la population parce que c'est un
clivage qui est souvent réactivée par
les populistes ou gagnant de la
modélisation qu'on ne perde la
mondialisation ça c'est des clivages
plus modernes dont on parle assez
souvent
perdu
autrement dit le clivage c'est un
conflit installé profondément dans une
société il se traduit dans la vie
politique par une ou plusieurs
structures partisanes des comportements
électoraux et des oppositions
idéologiques exprimé dans l'espace
public
alors on parle beaucoup de l'ukraine
bien qui va ge qui était très présent en
ukraine après maintenant ça a beaucoup
changé avec ce que tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis 2014 c'était le clivage
entre pro européen et pro russes par
exemple donc chaque chaque comment dire
chaque état où chaque
société je pourrais te le dire comme ça
à ses propres clivage évidemment
fonction de son histoire et de sa
construction nationale
daniel louis cellier seiler pardon
évoque trois éléments qui permettent de
mu en comprendre les ressorts une
division observable permettant de
distinguer les acteurs sur le fondement
de critères objectifs comme la classe
sociale la religion l'ethnie la prise de
conscience par les acteurs de cette
division qui trouvent une motivation
pour passer à l'action une traduction en
termes d'organisation
stefano bartolini
nous dit d orientation selon des
intérêts ancré dans la structure sociale
des orientations culturelles
idéologiques enraciné dans le système
normatif et des modèles de comportement
exprimé dans l'appartenance à une
organisation est repérable dans l'action
le clivage est une structure qui trouve
donc à s'exprimer sous plusieurs formes
ce sont ces formes qui lui permettent de
passer d'un état potentiel à un état
réel et j'ai envie de même de dire que
certains clivages sont très actifs à
certains moment et vont retomber dans
cette potentialité à d'autres moments
donc vont tout doucement ça soupire
ça peut être chez nous en tout cas en
belgique le clivage laïcs religieux
religieux
qui n'est pas toujours pertinent quoi
enfin laïcs catholiques qui n'est pas
toujours pertinent mais il suffit qu'il
y ait une décision par exemple par
rapport à l'école pour que ce qui va ch
soit réactivée de même le clivage
linguistique n'est pas toujours actif
mais à certains moments on sent des
moments de tension ou de crise où le
clivage se réactiver ou la population
finalement se polarise
comment les clivages se forme-t-il selon
vincent de corby terre jean domingue et
dessine hard et qui sont des chercheurs
belges eux la constitution d'un clivage
s'opère selon un processus en trois
temps rigoureusement ordonné le premier
temps est celui de la prise de
conscience dans une partie de la société
d'un déséquilibre d'une menace ou d'une
injustice majeure au ressenti comme tel
pourtant sur un enjeu de grande
importance qui touche concrètement la
vie des personnes le deuxième temps est
celui de l'auto organisation des
citoyens décidés à réagir contre ce
déséquilibre et qui se regroupent au
niveau de la société civile pour
réclamer des réformes permettant un
rééquilibrage le troisième temps est
celui de la création d'un ou de
plusieurs partis politiques à
l'initiative de cette société civile
organisée qui cherche par cette création
a participé directement à la décision
politique pour se donner plus de chances
d'obtenir les fermes et ce compte est un
très bel exemple va être la constitution
des partis écologistes avec d'abord le
constat dans les années 70 de certains
enjeux environnementaux
certaines questions environnementales
qui ne trouvent pas de réponse il y aura
des mouvements des organisations qui
vont se mettre en place comme par
exemple je pense et amis de la terre ou
greenpeace avec certains action
et puis on va se rendre compte peut-être
que ce n'est pas suffisant et donc là il
ya la construction la structuration de
partis politiques qui vont défendre ses
intérêts dans
les gilets jaunes est un contre-exemple
puisqu'on a bien les étapes une et deux
mais on n'a pas la troisième étape les
gilets jaunes ont toujours décapité
toute tentative de structurer un parti
politique sur base de cette lutte et de
ce combat là
donc c'est un modèle qui est aussi
intéressant moi j'aime bien les petits
modèles comme ça parce que ça permet
vraiment aux élèves qui débute en
sciences sociales de de les appliquer de
manière très
simple puisque en fait il n'ya pas
trente six mille m éléments à mobiliser
ou à comprendre alors revenons sur l'ip
c'était rocade pose l'hypothèse d'une
grande inertie de ces clivages ou en
tout cas de leur traduction partisane
donc ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est
que tout ça est très difficile à changer
ces clivages une fois que s'est
installée c'est vraiment comme si c'est
fait vraiment avec du plomb des déploie
qui vont vraiment ancrée ces clivages et
empêcher qu'on puisse les changes et les
modifier les bouger c'est ça que ça veut
dire inertie c'est une belle image
de corby terre l'a traduit ainsi les
partis nés dans le cadre d'un clivage
bénéficient d'une longue durée de vie a
priori proche de celle du clivage qui
leur a donné naissance il faut que ce
clivage se dénoue pour que certains
partis perdre éventuellement leur raison
d'être voilà par exemple les pas les
partis politiques écologistes ils sont
toujours là ils n'ont pas disparu parce
qu'il se basait sur un clivage par
contre dans certains pays il ya eu
l'émergence de partis le pirate je ne
sais pas si ça vous dit quelque chose
notamment dans certains pays scandinaves
bien les partis pirates ont disparu du
champ politique où certains partis qui
sont vraiment liées à une personne
peuvent disparaître du champ politique
sauf si on trouve vraiment une
correspondance entre ce parti politique
et un clivage dans la société
là ça devient vraiment quelque chose de
solide et de durable donc si vous voulez
créer un parti politique essayer d'abord
de détecter les clivages dans la société
pour pouvoir le fond et
donc là on était sur la première période
le gel envoyée c'est le héritte hier ici
à vraiment toujours des bons mots pour
proposer son travail c'est très
séduisant sur sur la forme
c'est très plaisant lire cette hypothèse
a été presque aussitôt discuter la
question s'est posée de l'évolution de
la possibilité d'évolution de ces
clivages car ce présupposé
du gel est problématique si les clivages
anciens demeure et constitue et continue
pardon à structurer la vie politique
contemporaine par un effet d'hystérésis
ne risque-t-on pas d'observer un
décalage entre des cadres politiques
partis ou idiologie fortement ancrée
dans ses structures et de nouvel an les
identités et aspirations qui ne relèvent
pas de ses clivages donc finalement
est-ce qu'on n'aura pas un décalage
puisque ces clivages là sont bétonnées
avec des partis qui les chapeaute
si il ya des nouvelles évolutions à bien
finalement ça va rester vautré bétonné
et donc c'est pas très logique il ya un
problème peut-être théorique alors ici
vous voyez c'est hystérésis c'est un mot
qui veut dire que les fai continue même
si la cause a disparu par exemple vous
faites une pincette et vous arrêtez de
vous pincer bien vous continuez à avoir
mal après a pas un set après avoir cessé
de vous pincer donc là il ya un
hystérésis c'est ça
hein d'hystérésis
la pertinence de ces questions est
particulièrement avéré pour ce qui
concerne les partis politiques et ont au
moins une double fonction la
présentation des candidats aux élections
et l'animation du débat politique or si
les parties de ness des clivages il
contribue naturellement à les maintenir
opérationnelle un don qui vont les
entretenir voilà le parti nationaliste
flamand va tout faire pour alimenter
cette opposition entre flamands et
wallons par exemple on a parti
nationaliste français va tout faire pour
continuer à alimenter ce clivage entre
nationaux ou patriote c'est le mot qu'il
utilise actuellement et les étrangers
donc on va chaque fois revenir avec
nouvelles de nouvelles de nouvelles
images nouveaux exemples nouveaux termes
nouvelles idées pour que ce clivage
reste actif puisqu'il leur survie dépend
de ce clivage peu comme si vous
dépendiez de votre potager et bien vous
allez l'entretenir évidemment est bien
ici c'est la même chose ils
entretiennent leur potager
vivant or si les parties naissent des
clivages il contribue naturellement à
les maintenir au personnel la question
est donc de déterminer jusqu'où ils sont
en mesure de les maintenir en débit en
dépit d'un certain décalage avec la
réalité sociale où se trouve alors le
point de rupture
l'arrivée dans le paysage partisan
électorale des écologistes et d'extrême
droite n'a pas manqué comme nous l'avons
évoqué de susciter de nombreuses
réévaluations des clivages proposé par
l'ip sète hérault cannes
on parle notamment d'une révolution
silencieuse
où des générations en rupture avec le
matérialisme le fait d'avoir beaucoup
d'objets et ce tous considérés par
rapport aux biens matériels qui avait
prévalu jusqu alors l'augmentation du
niveau de prospérité la question de la
qualité de vie de l'épanouissement
personnel aurait entraîné une évolution
générale vers des valeurs postmoderne
rendant moins opérant les clivages
traditionnels
à partir de cette hypothèse plusieurs
travaux ont établi un lien entre la
révolution post matérialiste et
l'émergence des partis écologistes en
europe le retour en force de l'extrême
droite dans le paysage politique a
conduit au même type de réflexion autour
par exemple de l'idéologie de l'idée
d'une contre révolution silencieuse pour
reprendre les termes de pierrot in iasi
et de la montée en puissance d'une
opposition entre les identitaires et les
cosmopolites donc voilà
vous voyez qu'on peut continuer à
construire sur cette théorie de lipsett
et rock'n en disant tout simplement il
ya eu d'autres révolutions qui sont
passés sous les radars et qui ont elles
mêmes permis l'émergence de nouveaux
partis qui ont une existence durable
dans le paysage politique les partis
écologistes et les partis d'extrême
droite
ou nationaliste où j'ai même envie de
dire mais ce n'est qu'une interprétation
personnelle patriotes
en partant ou souverainistes enjeux dire
en partant de l'hypothèse puissante de
lipsett héros cannes on s'est efforcé de
déterminer quelle nouvelle révolution
suffisamment significatives avaient pu à
l'instar des révolutions nationales et
industriel mené à une recombinaison les
clivages historiques en effet si l'on
reste fidèle à ce modèle un clivage ne
peut émerger sans révolution alors que
toute nouvelle division politique aussi
spectaculaire soit elle ne saurait être
qualifiée de clivage au sens propre du
terme
daniel louis c'est leur a bien montré
que l'usagé de ce terme pouvait être
abusif et contribué à faire perdre le
sien en faire perdre le sens initial
pascal delfosse à noter que nous
disposions pas du recul nécessaire bah
oui parce que l'ip sète hérault can i is
analyses tu voyais remonte jusqu'au 16e
siècle
donc il faut une approche très
historique mais nous aujourd'hui on n'a
pas encore le recul suffisant pour dire
ah tiens oui là en effet on est on est
face à une révolution
sociale technologiques économiques
donc ça c'est un peu le problème
d'aujourd'hui par rapport à cette
théorie qui s'est basé sur vraiment des
temps longs et nous sommes dans le temps
court alors on peut parler bien sûr de
la révolution de la mondialisation par
exemple avec l'apparition des formations
politiques souverainistes donc tout à
l'heure ce que je disais c'est un peu
une bêtise je me suis un peu avancée par
rapport à ce qu'ils disent ici
n'est ce pas la réactivation de clivage
solidement implantés et qui retrouve une
vigueur nouvelle sous l'effet d'une
mondialisation qui rejouent la question
de l'ouverture et de la fermeture des
sociétés et ce sur plusieurs plans
économiques ou culturelles
troisième temps après le gel et le dégel
la débâcle
on émettra ici l'hypothèse que la
révolution qui a eu lieu et qui encore à
l'oeuvre n'est pas de nature politique
même si elle a des conséquences
politiques dont il est question ici mais
anthropologique en substance là où
lipsett erkan forme et l'hypothèse d'un
gel des structures partisanes fondée sur
de solides clivages du fait de leur
inertie et d'autres évoquaient un
possible dégel n'assiste-t-on pas un
véritable débâcle qui emporte tout sur
son passage ce s et ce phénomène pardon
n'est-il pas le fruit de la
pulvérisation démocratique constater la
fragmentation politique est aujourd'hui
un lieu commun elle se caractérise entre
autres par la dispersion et la
volatilité des voix
les fidélités à tel ou tel camp s'étiole
nous qu'elles disparaissent
les citoyens papillonne doute ils vont
d'un parti à l'autre et se pose de plus
en plus rarement l'abstention n'est du
rejet des forces politiques en
compétition d'un manque de confiance
dans les institutions et plus gravement
encore d'une fatigue démocratique
relevant du daim à quoi bonnis mhz de
plus en plus partagé les gens ne vont
plus voter en disant à quoi bon toutes
façons c'est toujours la même chose et
tout ça donc on est sur un temps qui est
radicalement différent de celui où on
allait voter comme nos parents avaient
voté par rapport à une identité de
classe ou une conscience de classe par
exemple
où ça peut être aussi un attachement
à un clivage par exemple catholiques
laïcs
la pulvérisation et démocratique au sens
où elles se fondent sur une conception
très horizontale et même bassiste de
l'action politique dans laquelle
l'autorité verticale est rejeté et plus
encore la prise en considération de
chaque voie individuelle est vue comme
la condition même de l'acceptation de la
vie en commun ce qui conduit à une
aporie une aporie c'est un problème
théorique ou comment dire une un
paradoxe théorique
le nombre de partis est considérable
mais aussi du fait d'une incapacité à se
fédérer donc on a de plus en plus à
cette fragmentation
de l'espace politique où il ya plein de
petits partis qui apparaissent ou
valérie pécresse va fonder son mouvement
partant des républicains ou edouard
philippe va fonder son mouvement et
ainsi de suite l'augmentation du nombre
de groupes parlementaires à l'assemblée
nationale peut être aussi un indicateur
il faut savoir qu'à l'assemblée
nationale t'as pas forcément le
découpage en parti politique parce que
l'objectif c'est d'avoir un certain
nombre de députés dans son groupe pour
avoir du temps de parole est donc
parfois on a des partis qui ça qui
s'associent et parfois un départ qui
suffisamment au go que pour avoir des
tendances donc on a une partie une
franche de d'un parti qu'il va former
son propre groupe
les députés se supportent de plus en
plus mal
la discipline des grands groupes qui
oblige à en rabattre sur ses propres
convictions
et donc on arrive à ce concept d'ego
démocrate
et 2go démocratie en démocratie il faut
pourtant savoir transiger et accepter de
subir une loi contient pour légitime en
raison même de l'autorité symbolique qui
s'attache à elle de la légitimité des
institutions qui la produisent de la
rationalité et de l'ouverture du
processus qui en permet l'adoption oui
en effet un quand tu remontes sur les
grands penseurs de la philosophie
politique comme par exemple holmes il
nous dit dans
le léviathan que on va tous s'associer
on va laisser une partie de notre
liberté pour s'associer au sein d'un
contrat social il ya tout est
comment dire ce courant fils de la
philosophie politique du contrat social
un qui nous dit ben voilà on va
s'associer ensemble par ce contrat
social pour avoir une protection et donc
finalement la loi eh bien c'est ce qui
ressort de ce contrat social il faut
accepter la loi il faut accepter les
règles du jeu même si la loi était
opposée parce que c'est ce qui permet un
vivre ensemble moi je trouve que là mais
ce n'est qu'un avis on touche quelque
chose d'essentiel dont c'était mais là
je sors un peu du cadre de l'article
c'est que maintenant plus personne
n'accepte la loi d'ailleurs parfois on
voit passer sur les réseaux sociaux est
il temps de désobéir ce genre de titre
m'énerve profondément étant donné que je
trouve plutôt que c'est la difficulté à
obéir aujourd'hui qui est problématique
bonjour xx agent secret je t'appellerai
agent secret alors bienvenue sur ce
stream tu as m2 en sciences politiques
c'est bien j'ai des sujets de
conversation j'ai un capital culturel
mais pour ce qui est de trouver un taf
oui je suis bien d'accord avec toi un
bon jour propice je n'avais pas vu que
tu étais là désolé tu vas bien oui non
mais c'est sûr attention ici c'est une
chaîne de sciences sociales et sciences
politiques moi j'ai jamais dit qu'il
fallait faire des sciences sociales des
sciences politiques moi j'ai
j'ai une licence à l'époque s'appelait
une licence en sciences politiques bas
aussi j'ai galéré beaucoup j'ai
travaillé dans la grande distribution
j'ai travaillé comme délégué commercial
et puis maintenant je suis dans
l'enseignement donc en effet
ici
c'est pas en termes de débouchés
qu'on travaille c'est vraiment pour se
cultiver pour pour aider en tout cas
ceux qui sont dans ce système là quoi
voilà mais je suis d'accord avec toi moi
j'ai des élèves qui viennent me voir en
disant ah tiens je vais faire des
sciences sociales
parce qu'il ya pas que ça en science
politique je pense que sociaux
entrepôt c'est le même combat mais je
leur dis attention il ya aucun débouché
quoi c'est sûr
à moins que tu es puisque tu as palais
de capitale culturelle à moins que tu es
du capital social à mon avis si tu as du
capital social
tu peux accéder à certaines à certains
postes à certains certaines choses plus
facilement peut-être en tout cas en
belgique c'est le cas en france c'est
sans doute plus
comment dire plus formalisé voilà
donc
c'est ce que nous dit ici
héritière dans le monde actuel on est
dans une sorte d'écho démocratie où
chacun veut finalement que ces idées
l'emportent ou ne pas appliquer les lois
qui lui sont défavorables qu'ils ne
pensent pas juste et on peut évidemment
faire un lien avec ce qui s'est passé
durant le vide où le pouvoir politique
édicter des règles mais elles étaient
fortement contestée alors vous allez me
dire oui mais c'est parce que elle était
contestable mais c'est justement ça
l'objet c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n'hésite
pas à contester sa certaines règles même
si elles sont parfois légale un bon là
il y avait comment dire les pouvoirs
spéciaux et des des mesures d'urgence
qui avait été prise donc où le côté
démocratique était parfois un peu effacé
mais dans plein de cas il ya des règles
et les gens disent oui mais moi je ne
vais pas respecter ça et donc je trouve
que ce
comment dire ce jeu
ce terme d'ego démocratie est
intéressant maintenant
voilà je trouve qu'il n'est pas très
étayée par des faits et il manque tout
l'aspect empirique pour le dire ok on
est vraiment sur un concept intéressant
mais s'il ya une autre frappe à ginals
peut-être ça renvoie voilà ici un
article il faudrait voir peut-être
il ya toujours des logiques collectives
dans le comportement électoral légaux
démocrate tend à s'y soustraire et oui
parce que la politique c'est du vivre
ensemble c'est du collectif en fait ils
voient le monde a sa propre mesure mais
lui reste en réalité imperméable
anomique alors là on fait référence à
durkheim ce avec une queue l'anomie sa
décalage entre les règles et les buts
d'une société et donc c'est au sein de
ce décalage que né l'anomie c'est quand
les individus ne comprennent plus le
sens des règles ne voit plus pourquoi il
faut respecter les règles donc c'est
très juste un parce que je pense aussi
qu'on est dans une société pleinement
anomique
comment faire quand les règles nous dit
poppy semble dévoyé comme les conseils
de défense pour une crise sanitaire
oui c'est sûr c'est sûr que dans le
contexte de crise c'est un peu plus
comment dire c'est un peu plus compliqué
d'analysé mais je sais pas si tu es
d'accord avec moi quand on est dans le
dans le quotidien bon là on est revenu
quand même quelque chose de
de plus quotidien en tout cas pour nos
vies à nous même s'il ya toujours la
crise par rapport à la crise
ukrainiennes ou avant la crise sanitaire
il ya quand même des des règles qui sont
édités et que ma personne ne respecte
tout le monde s'assied dessus la loi on
s'en fout quoi quelque part et au moins
je trouve que la désobéissance et est
partout alors après c'est un jugement de
valeur que je fais ici mais c'est par
rapport à cet article je trouve que
c'est assez juste quand tu trouves que
que c'est pas c'est pas juste se cette
analyse de dire qu' on est dans une
sorte de dégoût démocratie où finalement
chacun fait sa propre synthèse alors tu
vas me dire c'est très sain
démocratiquement oui peut-être
mais
ce que nous dit l'auteur c'est que y'a
plus d'identité de classe ou d'identité
commune qui fait que finalement on va
être ensemble
et ça pose problème quand tu fais la
politique puisque la politique c'est
justement construire un vivre ensemble
or si chacun veut rester un atom ça va
être difficile de faire de la matière
collective que c'est un petit peu ça le
l'objet de l'article
anomique souvent hyper connectés on
n'insistera jamais assez sur le rôle de
la technique dans cette évolution
anthropologique mais je crois enfin moi
je suis marxien voulu dire ça comme ça
sur les deux premières révolutions alors
je sais pas si vous étiez là au départ
sur les deux premières évolutions et à
la révolution bien sûr la révolution
industrielle
et puis la révolution nationale ça c'est
le modèle de lipsett hero call en fait
on va voir la construction de des
clivages traditionnels qui traverse la
société
mais en tant que que lecteur de marx
j'ai envie de dire qu' il ya des
évolutions technologiques la révolution
industrielle très certainement mais la
révolution nationale aussi et donc en
fait au début de chaque révolution il ya
quand même une évolution technologique
en tout cas c'est mon sentiment profond
comment faire quand la doxa c'est ce
qu'on avait lui précédemment je suis
assez d'accord avec toi aussi bien du
côté des dirigeants que des citoyens oui
oui oui hein tu as raison un des
dirigeants aussi c'est incroyable alors
en belgique en tout cas c'est improbable
nombre de dirigeants politiques qui
finalement il ya une décision qui est
prise au niveau du conseil des ministres
ils sortent et hop directement sur
twitter ils tirent des missiles sur la
décision qu'ils viennent de prendre
puisqu'ils ont participé parce que chez
nous il faut partis de la coalition et
donc les politiques eux-mêmes s'assied
sur les lois mais ce qui est encore plus
dangereux finalement que les citoyens
parce que il y as d'escaudes des
constructions par le haut si je suis
tout à fait d'accord c'est vraiment très
très intéressant ce que tu dis est en
effet quoi
exactement
non mais chez moi je suis d'accord avec
toi aimer c'est ce qui est dit dans
l'article d'ailleurs et ce matin quand
j'ai lu le l'article j'ai pensé à cette
idée là dessus on se rejoint par rapport
à l'analyse
il ne néglige pas forcément l'engagement
collectif il s'émeut ils se mobilisent
ils like nouvelle manière de voter où
ils bloquent et ne parlent qu'à ceux qui
lui ressemblent et pour finir il
soliloque mais j'ai envie de dire
parfois tu te pose même la question auto
propres échelle 1 sur youtube il ya des
gens qui arrivent et ils sont tellement
ils veulent tellement
comment dire imposer leur vision sans
tenir compte de mon travail à moi qui ai
une proposition théorique qui se base
sur certains travaux castrés manges tu
es obligé de les les bloquer quoi de les
éjecter de la chaîne parce que voilà il
de trop le truc est donc même quand tu
veux pas tu veux pas soliloquer ben
finalement tu en arrives à soliloquer ma
sueur twitch j'ai encore banni personne
d'aucun donc ça c'est le côté positif me
suis dit assure twitch je suis quand
même beaucoup moins égaux démocrates
pour reprendre les termes qui sont ici
mais voilà c'est vraiment quand j'ai lu
cette partie que j'ai aussi l'image de
trump qui a pas forcément une ligne
politique et qui va réagir comme ça une
fois une fois dans un sens une fois dans
l'autre sans aucune cohérence comme ça
vraiment j'ai trouvé que se concertent
d'ego démocratie allait très bien à
donald trump
il n'est pas le seul nous on a aussi
certains hommes ou femmes politiques
chez nous qu'ils le font très bien or
l'émergence de lego démocrate va à
l'encontre de ce processus de
collectivisation de la politique est à
l'oeuvre à travers l'activation des
clivages car ce qu'est ce que la
politique c'est une opération qui
consiste à construire de l'unité à
partir du pluriel c'est bien dire il ya
là la qualité de ceux de cet article
c'est sa qualité littéraire c'est très
intrigué à lire parfois il ya des
articles c'est de vraie purge à lire
très intéressant sur le fond et la
méthodologie est vraiment vraiment
repoussoir sur la forme ici j'ai envie
de dire c'est un peu l'un vers ce même
s'il ya des choses sur le fond qui sont
intéressantes mais après on reviendra
sur la critique de l'article ce que j'ai
vraiment envie d'en faire une même si
voilà je suis pas bien placé pour
critiquer un article vu que j'ai
personnellement jamais fait de l'article
scientifique je trouve ça un peu mesquin
la pulvérisation contemporaine fait
directement barrage à cette opération
parce qu'elle s'attaque aux instruments
même qui la rendait possible
c'est ce qu'on disait
dans le che est on peut aller plus loin
en se demandant si notre société est
encore capable de construire autre chose
que des clivages éphémère à l'heure des
petites phrases des clashs et autres
punchline
tout devient politique est finalement
plus rien ne les et ça je trouvé ça très
juste aussi comme lecture ou par exemple
il va se passer un
épi événement vraiment quelque chose de
très anodin et directement ça va être
repris par les politiques qui vont qui
vont ensuite et ça va être repris sur
les matinale à la radio dans les médias
et donc finalement on va faire tourner
cette chose qui était totalement anodine
un événement qui devient un événement
politique je retrouve vraiment cette
impression là que j'ai parfois quand je
regarde les médias il ne demeure alors
ou twitter il ne demeure alors qu'un
précipité saumâtre la polémique elle
exerçait l'exacerbation pardon bêtes des
passions
or aujourd'hui quand se produit une
forme de coagulation politique j'aime
bien vraiment le côté littéraire ses
métaphores qui sont prises par l'auteur
tel le mouvement des gilet jaune en 2018
le fruit en est un agrégat désordonnée
de revendications qui ne semble avoir
d'autres cohérence qu'un sentiment
confus d'abandon et un rejet des élites
cette masse informe ne réussit pas à se
traduire par une organisation politique
capable de se construire de construire
un programme d'action et c'est très
juste aussi je trouve puisque les
jumelles les jaunes n'ont débouché sur
rien politiquement en tout cas sur
aucune structure politique alors que
c'était quand même un mouvement social
d'une certaine ampleur on peut aussi
faire un lien avec les mouvements anti
passe ou du mouvement contre les mesures
sanitaires en général qui finalement
amalgame est des gens de gauche des gens
de droite des complotistes des
simplement des mères de famille ou des
pères de famille et ils avaient tous
finalement une lecture et des visions
totalement différentes
et donc c'est vraiment par ces éléments
que l'auteur nous dit on est face à une
pulvérisation démocratique puisqu'il n'y
a aucune aucune conscience collective
même dans ces luttes là alors que par
exemple d'autres mouvements comme les
mouvements sociaux plus classiques comme
peut-être même les luttes les grèves des
étudiants pour le climat ou la polémique
la
demande et à la manif pour tous là il y
avait sans doute un fondement sur des
clivages qui existait déjà mais c'est
vrai que le nouveau mouvement sociaux
ils sont sans grand clivage quoi parce
ce clivage vague en effet de deux
peuples contre élite
nous émettrons l'hypothèse que la
pulvérisation démocratique a conduit à
une telle débâcle des clivages que dont
la structuration de la vie politique
subsistent à titre principal des
facteurs personnels le recours à la
séduction la communication massive et
tout azimut le rapport direct au peuple
la simplification des enjeux sont la
conséquence de cette révolution
anthropologique qu'on le déplore ou non
cette personnalisation est installé et
durablement
bon c'est intéressant parce que aussi
quand tu vois l'évolution des partis
politiques le mouvement en marche c'est
quand même emmanuel macron et ses
copains quoi c'est emmanuel macron qui
est le centre de en marche qu'elle
élèverait le véritable programme
politique si ce n'est faire du
libéralisme avec emmanuel macron et
quand tu vois aussi la mue de marine le
pen ici qui va venir justement sur
beaucoup d'aspects personnel devient
beaucoup moins clivant ce n'est plus sur
des clivages totalement nationaliste va
un petit peu cherché des mesures à
gauche ou des mesures sociales
je vais pas dire que c'est des mesures
de gauche mais des mesures sociales qui
restent parfois sur sur des thèmes de
pure extrême droite voilà c'est
questionnant parce que finalement tu as
vraiment une explosion je trouve qu'il a
il a raison sur le constat une explosion
des clivages pour une atomisation
finalement des des électeurs mais aussi
du personnel politique
est ce que l'article parle de la place
prépondérante des acteurs que sont les
entreprises twitter facebook dans la
décision qui transforma société tout à
faire ils vont ils en parlent pas de
manière
profonde et totalement développées mais
dit il le dit voilà que c'est
vraiment le monde numérique actuelle le
microcosme numérique ou non pardon
l'environnement numérique avec twitter
avec facebook avec tout ça qui fait qu'
on en arrive cette pulvérisation
mais après il rentre pas dans les
détails parce que c'est pas son objet
les clivages traditionnels décrit par
l'ip sète hérault kahn qui est vraiment
la grosse théorie de base des clivages
institut situé arrivés en cours de
stream en fait au début du stream
j'expliquais cette théorie des clivages
de lipsett héros cannes
travaille encore le corps social ne
serait ce que dans la rhétorique des
acteurs qui pèsent aussi sur la réalité
même si ce poids est de plus en plus
faible est en effet
tout à l'heure voilà dans ce meeting
zemmour a parlé plusieurs fois de la
droite et tout ça d'ailleurs on en
reparlera je dis pas ce que c'est c'est
quand même hallucinant
son discours est hallucinant plusieurs
points de vue à plus d'un titre
mais il a quand même mobilisé ce qu'il
va gauche droite donc il ya toujours ces
clivages qui sont là mais comme le dit
l'auteur s'ils sont de moins en moins
effectif quelque part mais chez ans
après l'échéance le fossé semble se
creuser entre des acteurs politiques à
la recherche d'une martingale un don
d'un commandite d'une recette pour
convaincre et agir et des égos démocrate
mue par un désir inassouvi entre
impuissance et frustration la
pulvérisation démocratique risque de
faire des dégâts la première victime en
élective âge désormais éparpillés façon
puzzle
bon voilà alors je dois dire que
bon c'est quand même moi qui choisis les
articles mais c'est pas forcément un bon
choix quoi ce n'est pas forcément un bon
choix parce que je trouve que c'est pas
un bon exemple de ce qu'est la science
politique pour moi c'est pas vraiment un
article de science politique alors je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez dans le
chat je sais pas si tu as encore l'agent
secret
toi qui as un m2
on sûr politique mais pour moi c'est pas
un vrai article parce qu'ils manquent
tout l'aspect empirique on est plus sur
un essai
voire à certains égards un pamphlet
ou de la philosophie politique mais pas
vraiment de la science politique parce
qu'il ya vraiment très peu dans peary
maintenant il faut pas jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain il ya quand même des
qualités dans cet article moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé le côté littéraire mais
c'est un peu le problème quand tu fais
trop de littérature dans ton article
finalement
la tendance assez à chercher parfois là
la belle formule
au détriment du fond je pense
il y avait tout un travail de bourdieu
justement par rapport à la forme et le
fond pour éviter toute séduction
de la forme
sur le fond et donc c'est pour rester le
fond de moi je préfère en effet un
article bien chiant mais où tout est
carré derrière tandis qu'ici voilà il ya
très peu d'éléments de bibliographie
aussi qui permettent vraiment de
vérifier bon ils sont là
mais c'est quand même assez léger à ce
niveau là aussi donc moi je le placerais
plutôt dans dans philosophie politique
dans cette philosophie politique plutôt
que dans la recherche de sciences
sociales ou articles présentant une
recherche de sciences politiques
maintenant il ya des choses aussi qui
sont intéressantes c'est il ya des
choses qui sont relativement justes on
les a dit d'ailleurs ensemble dans le
chat ça c'est une chose je trouve ça
toujours intéressant de revenir sur la
théorie de licques sète hérault kahn qui
est quand même la base dont on veut
aborder les clivages moi je pense que ça
reste toujours d'actualité les clivages
alors ça dépend lesquels on prend
et puis ce qui est aussi
peut-être intéressant
mais c'est toutes les ouvertures que ça
fait 1
voilà même si je trouve que les concepts
d'ego démocratie c'est quand même des
choses un peu facile est ce qu'elles
font consensus dans le champ
scientifique
il faudra aller vérifier quoi et puis il
ya quelque chose qui me dérange
c'est que j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
quand même
un peu de normatif dans cet article il
ya quand même du jugement de valeur sûre
sur la politique actuelle et
personnellement je préfère unis sciences
sociales totalement aseptisé quoi
totalement s'est jamais possible à 100%
mais on est on est tellement parfois
critiquée de l'extérieur sur les
sciences sociales et parfois même de
l'intérieur sur la crédibilité des
sciences sociales que voilà c'est ce
genre d'article qui donne de l'eau au
moulin pour pour dire ben vous voyez
c'est plutôt du débat d'opinion et
sciences sociales que réellement une
approche scientifique des phénomènes
sociaux voilà monsieur sait qu'un avis
évidemment
alors tu nous dis est ce que l'article
parle de la place prépondérante non on
en a parlé en tous les cas c'est vrai
que c'est agréable à lire oui et puis
toutes ces formules sont sont très
percutante après voilà moi je le
garderai pas pour une recherche de
sciences sociales mais personnellement
pour mes opinions pour comment lire
faire évoluer mes opinions et nourrir un
petit peu ma réflexion politique c'est
intéressant c'est intéressant voilà
c'est comme ça moi je le classe vraiment
dans la philosophie politique